[Musique]
et nous sommes en direct avec gilbert
collard député européen est reine
cyrille isaac sibille médecin député
modem 12e circonscription du rhône
enfin loïc prud'hommes député la france
insoumise troisième circonscription de
gironde bonsoir messieurs merci d'être
avec nous en direct sur rt france donc à
retenir ce soir évidemment 20
départements qui ont été placés sous
surveillance renforcée en raison d'une
circulation accrue de l'épidémie 1 qui
bat malheureusement des records à
nouveau on pourrait faire l'objet de
mesures de confinement 1 nous par
exemple ile de france et d'autres
régions on l'a vu à partir du week-end
du 6 mars
en clair ça nous pend au nez cyrille
isaac sibille j'ai entendu comme vous et
vivement la conférence de presse dupré
milices admise à santé non je pense que
comme comme depuis le début
ce qu'il faut ce virus on s'attendre
woods surprise d'enfants par lui et je
pense que notre rôle en tout cas le road
ouvernement c'est d'anticiper de survie
courbe d'anticiper et prend des bonnes
mesures
jusqu'à maintenant effectivement on y
avait plein de la santé il est prête de
l'économie un maillot si le problème qui
ment de la santé mentale et de l'état
psychologique de nos concitoyens il faut
tenir compte au dos est propriétaire et
donc on anticipe en même temps si très
important c'est qu'on fait et
concertation territoriale
c'est important d'aller vers les îles
locaux vers les représentants des
départements pour comprendre ce qui se
passe et avoir une réponse adaptée et en
accord avec eux alors loïc prénomme
justement cette concertation
territoriale ça fait un sacré bout de
temps que les élus locaux la demande
depuis d'ailleurs le début de l'épidémie
enfin le gouvernement a compris a
entendu l'appel des régions parce que
jean castex avait l'air de dire que ça
ne date pas d'hier mais enfin c'est
quand même la première fois que les élus
locaux sont concertés à ce point et
qu'en tous cas les décisions au lieu
localement c'est une bonne chose
je sais pas s'il faut se réjouir ou pas
mais c'est surtout a dit jean castex et
qu'il continuait de surveiller sur l'île
concertent
mais ma question assez quand est ce qu
il agi parce que effectivement la
question des concertations avec les élus
territoriaux
elle a surtout à un autre et c'est celui
du contrôle des flux de population et on
a vu la situation de nice qui était
assez révélatrice où il ya eu des
concertations pour régler une ciste une
un problème qui n'a pas été réglé en
amont à savoir le contrôle des flux
notamment entre le fait de laisser
rentrer et eva rien parce qu'ils vivent
au col aucun contrôle efficace il
demande de tests pcr avant de rentrer
sur le territoire national et ça
provoque et le cas au volant à vue à
nice que l'on a vu à dunkerque et que
l'on commence à voir maintenant sur
vingt départements où la seule réponse
du gouvernement essaie de dire on va
surveiller
on va surveiller la progression des
variables mais le problème c'est qu'ils
ont laissé ces variants rentrer
massivement sur le territoire et que
maintenant tout semble hors de contrôle
alors vous pouvez conserver autant
d'élus locaux que vous voulez c'est vrai
que ça sera toujours mieux que de ne pas
le faire vu j'allais dire le manque de
l'inconséquence de gouvernement et je
pense que les locaux seront d'un apport
plutôt positif mais ça ne réglera pas
tout ce qui n'a pas été fait en amont et
notamment la question aussi de la
gestion des quantités de vaccins vous
parliez tout à l'heure de enfin
l'apparition du vaccin astrazeneca chez
les médecins généralistes en termes de
quantité c'est une catastrophe absolue
un flacons de dix doses par médecin
généraliste
je pense que les médecins vont apprécier
de penser qu'ils n'ont dans leur carnet
d adresses que 10 personnes
potentiellement vaccinable c'est juste
une plaisanterie en fait c'est pas comme
ça qu'on peut avancer rapidement sur la
vaccination tout ça sent la préparation
d'improvisation reviendra évidemment sur
la campagne de vaccination
gilbert collard il faut tout faire pour
retarder un confinement la stratégie du
gouvernement est très clair
vous êtes satisfait on ne peut pas être
satisfait d'en bas dans l'état de
situation pandémique où se trouveront
peut être angoissé que préoccupé parce
que aucune solution n'est la bonne dans
la mesure où le virus et ses variantes
sont méchamment mauvais ce que je
constate c'est que ont qu un discours
qui pulvérisait de l'intérieur parce
qu'il est contradictoire et ça c'est
très mauvais on nous dit que l'on
maîtrise le virus l'économétrie ce plus
des variants bon non franchement pour
des pour des blaireaux bon on savait
depuis des semaines et des semaines et
des semaines que les les variants était
là et que ce se greffer sur le sur le
virus toute cette mobilité des variants
bon aujourd'hui on nous dit que 20
départements sauf erreur de ma part sont
sous surveillance renforcée
ça veut dire quoi ça ça veut dire que le
gouvernement est atteint de
procrastination
il n'arrive pas à prendre de décision il
sait très bien que dans quelques jours
il va devoir confiné mais comme il a
peur d'une manière légitime du reste de
la manière dont ce confinement
qui est dû au fait essentiellement qu'on
n'a pas le lait place nécessaire de
réanimation parce que de nombreux alliés
ont été supprimés notamment en notamment
nice et à l'époque je crois même que
monsieur castex avaient des
responsabilités dans ce domaine on
peaufine voilà si on avait l'espace
médical sans laver les lits draghi
nations seraient pas obligées de prendre
toutes ces mesures mais comme on a peur
des réactions populaires liés à la
souffrance du confinement ont fait
presque des prêts anesthésie confine à
thouars chaque fois c'est à dire que on
nous laisse entendre qu'on va peut-être
et qu'on fera tout ce qu'on peut pour ne
pas faire mais qu'on va devoir faire en
même temps de perdre du temps alors s'il
faut confiné ils le savent à l'instant
où je parle
ils n'ont pas besoin de quatre cinq six
jours de plus et tout ce jeu dialectique
de communication nous mêmes notre
l'occupé m'inquiète voilà je je ne jette
la pierre à personne parce que le moment
est difficile et que ce serait d'une
prétention inouïe que de vouloir détenir
ici la vérité mais du point de vue que
s'ils voulaient de ski et de ce qui est
perçu de ce qui est de ses vécus ce
n'est pas très bon en ce qui concerne
les vaccins par exemple monsieur fisher
avait violemment critiqué le vaccin
astrazeneca est aujourd'hui s'il devient
une espèce d'affichage publicitaire
parlante lors de la conférence de presse
comment comprendre la jeunesse comment
comprendre que entre le entre le moment
où il avait déconseillé aux soignants de
moselle de prendre ce vaccin est
maintenant les choses ont changé banque
qui a eu des études que j'ignore j'en
sais rien mais tout cela fait l'effet
d'une espèce de deux déambulations
erratique voilà essais et c'est vraiment
très très angoissant
qu'est ce qu'on peut dire d'autre on a
le sentiment que
les maîtriser rien n'est contrôlé et
surtout via les dits essentiels mans
voilà ça type load dupont c'est surtout
compétences de confinement y compris
nous les journalistes
voilà comme si c'était un risque
potentiel on oublie peut-être qu'on est
confiné partiellement depuis quand même
fin octobre je vous le rappelle en
messieurs qu'on va plus au restaurant
qu'on ne sort plus le soir qu'on ne va
plus au musée plus au cinéma on a
peut-être le droit d'aller travailler et
éventuellement d'aller faire les courses
mais c'est tout il ya une forme voilà de
résignation vous le sentez comme ça loïc
prud'hommes des de la part des français
ou alors on se dit qu un confinement
strict ce serait peut-être encore pire
j'ai pas de résignation je pense que il
ya effectivement de l'incompréhension
parce que tout ça est quand même
largement improvisé il ya aussi une
grande attente sur ces questions de
vaccination et et que le gouvernement
n'est pas en mesure aujourd'hui d'y
répondre puisque qui manque déjà légende
du 75 ans n'ont pas de castres se faire
vacciner et je double vous l'assuré ici
en gironde la même chose et je le vis
directement bois pour mes proches c'est
impossible c'est faire vacciner et dès
cette année d'un constat d'échec aussi
sur cette question d'approvisionnement
où il ya des contrats opaques qui ont
été passés avec l'union européenne et
qui aboutissent aujourd'hui à ce fiasco
complet
on a aussi cette question qui a été
évoqué qu'en fait tout ça est fait
pourquoi parce qu'on a des hôpitaux qui
sont dans tension et c'est aussi un
échec du gouvernement qui a su trouver 5
milliards pour renflouer les air france
klm fn qui a pas trouvé le premier euro
pour renforcer notre système hospitalier
dont les français sont pas résignés ils
sont juste
débailly de voir à quel point on peut on
peut après un an continuer à improviser
alors que on devrait avoir un
gouvernement qui agit et ça c'est quand
même juste incroyable que aujourd'hui on
est qu'aucune action qu on attende de
voir dans cinq jours d'observer le de
surveiller de manière renforcée ici ou
là mais rien n'est fait rien n'est fait
pour le demander une licence d'office
pour la production des vaccins en nombre
alors que ça pouvait vraiment vous
sortir d'un mauvais pas rien rien n'est
fait en fait pour aider les français à
avoir le bout du tunnel et c'est surtout
ça qui le fmi le gouvernement à chaque
fois je sais pas si vous avez remarqué à
chaque conférence de presse qu'on se
fait attentivement le jeune y avait un
petit moment de satisfaction quand même
et défend son bilan c'est bien normal
je vous propose d'écouter jean castex
qui se dit on a bien fait de ne pas
confiner la dernière fois écouté avec le
président de la république nous avons
souhaité le mois dernier nous donner
tous les moyens d'éviter un nouveau
confinement que nous avions envisagé fin
janvier sur la base de projections qui
nous prédisaient une dégradation rapide
et brutale la situation cette décision
s'est avérée la bonne nous a permis de
gagner du temps or ce temps est précieux
car chaque jour nous avons un peu plus
de personnes vaccinées on appris après
quand même que jean castex a pas
toujours été d'accord avec emmanuel
macron sur le point de vue du
confinement bref mais là je m'adresse au
docteur pas seulement aux députés ainsi
release est que sybille on comprends pas
bien cette idée de rendre confine pas
donc on gagne du temps pour vacciner
on a vu les exemples au royaume uni en
israël la n'empêchait pas l'autre il y
avait des restrictions déconfinement en
israël et au royaume uni et on continuer
à vacciner massivement est ce que vous
comprenez cet argument du premier
ministre koichi médecin mm choses
premièrement il ya les gestes barrières
on apprend à trois armes
on a les gestes barrières on a le bon
film en mon â le vaccin moi je suis un
petit peu surpris par mes contradicteurs
camp quand il parle filmant des variants
quand j'entends des prud'hommes qui
vivent sinon il faudrait qu'on finit
plus ils faillirent a fallu s'attaquer
aux variants mais qu'est ce que vous
souhaitez le gouvernement une politique
plus autoritaire on a eu un débat à
l'assemblée nationale
c'est tout je pense que important et
c'est ce que fait le gouvernement
le gouvernement il anticipe donc il dit
grosso modo voilà les chiffres qui
montrent donc on peut être amené à
prendre telle décision pour prendre des
décisions on a beaucoup reproché
gouvernement ne pas avoir une approche
territoriale donc là il va consulter les
vaccins comme la règle comme l'a répété
olivier rang on est à flux tendu
chaque fois qu'on arrive qu'on a des
doses de vaccins ont les répercute de
manière transparente sur l'ensemble de
la population
vous parlez timo de la barre dans
pharmaceutique il faut quand même
rappeler ici assez extraordinaire moi je
suis médecin
en un an on est arrivé à fabriquer des
médecins plusieurs types de vaccins et
on était on est capable de faire cette
vaccination très large de la population
chose qui n'a jamais été fait alors
j'entends bien qu'on peut critiquer je
trouve que ce gouvernement
qu'est ce qu'il fait il anticipe il y
brosse mode les chiffres que montrer
dont on peut profiter pour tignes
réfléchisse barrières on continue la
vaccination et d'eau et donc je je je
pense que c'est là c'est vraiment la
laddh la botte la bonne attitude donc
bien évidemment gym l'issue mais samedi
le virus nous a posé beaucoup de
problèmes et des surprises chaque fois
qu'on a une solution
on a un problème face à solution ça
s'est passé lors des masques ça s'est
passé lors des tests maintenant les
vaccins ou progressent en avance et je
trouve que lorsqu'au lorsqu'on se
compare par rapport
on a les derniers chiffres par rapport
aux derniers 0 au public aux états
européens on est
la france est le pays qui fascine le
mieux c'est-à-dire qu'ils vaccinent les
gens qui sont de plus fragile donc au
dessus de 75 ans n'est pas le cas de nos
voisins où en est le pays on a hot
comptes allemands l'angleterre on va on
fait de la vaccination elle rappelle
donc je pense que quelqu'un est ce que
fait le gouvernement
il anticipe il rappelle qu' il y 3 via
les gestes barrière il ya la vaccination
il ya confinement si on n'arrive pas à
la jubilation évidemment la montée du
virus
et puis en même temps il ya ce qu'on ce
contrat serait bien tard donner votre
sang z3 alors j'essaye de distribuer la
parole pardonnez moi oui prud'hommes
saisi les convaincre sur ce point de la
vaccination
le hic prénomme vous voyez lever les
yeux au ciel civilisé que je voulais
plus de confinement en compliments sur
une plus stricte pas du tout je pointe
et lelas d'absence de contrôle de par
des tests sur les flux entrant ça que je
dis depuis des mois je le dis mais quand
on laisse les flux aller et venir
effectivement les variants et le boxer
et le virus se répand alors après les
éléments de langage autre satisfaction
le monsieur isaac sibille c'est personne
n'y croit on a bien vu que c'est une
catastrophe absolue l'on n'a pas les
vaccins en est d'abord accord les ont
produits mais on attend toujours la
liste de licences d'office pour que tout
le monde puisse en profiter
on revient que les pays riches qui va
aussi de les payer pauvres n'ont pas
accès aux vaccins et ont saisi d'une
épidémie mondiale et l'occident n'a pas
à me répond ce qui est mondial on
voulait c'est comme si on faisait rien
donc c'est passé assez étonnant en fait
deux
d'avoir un déni de la réalité at war
parisien denis barthe et moi je m'occupe
aussi pour distribuer la parole mais on
va écouter jean castex qui fait une
petite allusion qui en dit long sur
peut-être nos difficultés quant à la
vaccination écouter d'ici fin mars
les deux tiers des personnes de plus de
75 ans seront vaccinés et nous ouvrirons
début avril la vaccination aux plus de
65 ans pour autant nous dépendons de la
fabrication et de la livraison des doses
commandées par l'union européenne il
faudra nous armer de patience et ne
reste pas moins qu'à la mi-mai la
totalité des personnes de plus de 50 ans
se seront vus proposer une première
injection
gilbert collard alors on sent une voie
là soit un début d'aveu soit eh bien non
c'est pas de notre faute
il faut s'armer de patience et la faute
à l'europe qu'est ce que répond le
député européen vous êtes le député
européen répond que c'est c'est
l'échelle monumentale de 2,2 de l'union
européenne qui attaque qui a passé des
contrats d'une manière absolument pas
transparents les députés n'ont quasiment
pas pu voir les contrats il était quand
seul et donc on n'avait pas la
possibilité de les lire il y avait quand
on y avaient accès une surveillance dont
tout cela sans sent mauvais vraiment c
est on est on le voit dans ce cas dit
monsieur castex complètement dépendant
de la production dont ne contrôle pas
qu'on ne maîtrise pas l'or moi je
comprends que que je comprends qu'on
utilise des éléments de langage pour
défendre une politique mais là on est
dans la santé on est dans la vie dans la
survie dans la mort dont on n'a pas le
droit aux éléments de langage on n'a pas
le droit
les vaccins manque c'est un mensonge de
dire le contraire
on ne peut pas vacciner tout le monde et
la certitude d'avoir tout lé vaccin
n'existe même pas en ce qui concerne
astra on nous disait que c'était pas un
bon vaccin
on nous dit maintenant parce qu'il vient
combler la pénurie que c'est un taux
vaccins pour les gens entendent ils
enregistrent
10 de la même manière les centres de
vaccination qui devait être démultipliée
ne le sont pas de la même manière que
les lits d'hôpitaux qui devait être
démultipliée ne l'ont pas été que lis-je
démultiplier comble et comblée en
déficit ne l'ont pas été bon il ya une
situation erratique erratique et un
gouvernement qui gagne du temps alors la
question qu'il faudra se poser un jour
ou l'autre ils gagnent du temps sur quoi
sur la politique sur la santé sur
l'économie sur l'état psychique des
français ce gain de temps qui va le
payer au bout du compte il faut voir ce
qui se cache derrière les mots et il
faut pas fuir devant la situation
je crois que aucun aucun d'entre nous
n'arrivent droit de faire de la
politique là parce que c'est une affaire
de santé la réalité est que les vaccins
on en a pas suffisamment ils sont pas
livrés rappelez-vous le problème des
doses de la 6ème doors des complications
extraordinaire que ça a créé rappelez
vous des problèmes de l'acheminement des
vaccins
le problème de la réserve frigorifique
toutes les questions qui ont été posées
que les gens en dette dont on voudrait
appeler ce gouvernement à ne pas gagner
du temps mais à gagner des vies à gagner
des vies ça serait quand même autre
chose à notre programme voilà ce qui me
préoccupe et encore une fois je peux
comprendre quand on est dans un sens un
groupe qu'on descende avec les armes du
langage que l'on peut vous fournir mais
là on est plus dans le domaine
de la discussion politique un on est
dans le domaine de la de la vie et de la
mort et puis il peut taper à votre porte
comme la mienne donc faisons pas trop
les malins non plus vous êtes interpellé
par gilbert collard je vous demande
quelles réponses rapides parce qu'on va
a défait de la faim haussière à loïc
club rapidement face une crise comme ça
justement ce collage ou penseurs
politiques vous propos ne sont que
politique
quelque part j'attendrai de vous au ce
cirque tous timone pour ces cercles si
poudre et pour répondre aux français au
lieu d'agiter les peurs
chaque faux vous revenez sur astra astra
le professeur fisher et à leurs astres à
gilly est un bon vaccin dit lost hobo
vaccin n'essayez pas de produire de
faire la politique en disant d'un côté
voilà on a des doutes sur astrazeneca
rêvait d'une omlt chocolat
ne soyez pas défaitiste et sidya ni la
guerre y avec nous y arrêter de sada
politique
loïc le mot de la fin pour vous bien sûr
que cette question éminemment politique
et que cette année chef politique du
premier ministre à répondre aux besoins
sanitaires à protéger la population
française mais quand nous avons proposé
depuis des mois des solutions
alternatives quand nous avons demandé
des licences d'office quand nous avons
demandé la transparence sur les contrats
des vaccins pouces a été balayée d'un
revers de la main
le gouvernement pense en être plus
intelligent tout seul qu'en écoutant
d'autres avis on en est aujourd'hui dans
une situation qui est incroyablement
compliqué difficile pour tous les
français et les françaises qui sont face
à cette pandémie dinars il n'y a pas de
réponse moi je dis à ce niveau des
chèques à ce niveau même des
conséquences il faut en tirer les
conséquences des conséquences sanitaires
et les conséquences politiques
monsieur castaic n'est pas en mesure de
gérer
situation aujourd'hui ils doivent partir
et de laisser la place à quelqu'un qui
arrêtent de survie qui agit merci en
tout cas tous les trois gilbert collard
cyrille isaac sybille et loïc nomme
d'avoir été avec nous après donc cette
conférence de presse de jean castex